[Musique]
que serait nos Pathé chinois tourtières
ou frites sans le bon vieux ketchup
automatique et dans un test de goût il
fallait absolument inclure l'air
référence que c'est sûrement retrouvé
dans votre frigo c'est-à-dire le 11
aujourd'hui au CF marché des promenades
à Saint Bruno nos goutteurs et goûteuses
choisiront leurs préférés en testant
aussi les primos Canada sauce et Frances
place à la dégustation
à vos cuillères
est-ce que c'est un aliment que vous
avez régulièrement dans votre frigo oui
oui avec des petites ampères on n'a pas
le choix oui et puis ils vont pas le
vôtre est-ce que tu aimes les ketchup
oui c'est bon
[Rires]
donc ça peut être un condiment avec des
frites des hamburgers mais ça peut aussi
avoir un effet ressort dans certaines
recettes ça fait en fait un produit
incontournable dans la cuisine de
plusieurs personnes
moi j'ai vu du ketchup à Noël
sur la tortière
êtes-vous des consommatrices de ketchup
des enfants de même
c'est bon avec du ketchup
surprise on va voir la texture ça
commence pas bien
quand les regarde juste comme ça on a
beau essayer de chercher différents
profils c'est pas tellement évident
parce que c'est quand même un produit
très similaire de un à l'autre
qu'est-ce que vous achetez
habituellement
c'est la référence vous n'êtes pas la
seule
ça me semble un truc que je prends
toujours le hands
mais moi je dirais que c'est lui-même
vous avez 100% raison
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais t'es vraiment trop fan pour moi
pour qui bout en terme de gauche je
pense que les consommateurs s'attendent
à la référence qu'ils ont en tête fixer
soit un ketchup vraiment très
traditionnel type 1 probablement le
premier qui ont goûté puis que c'est
devenu la référence dans leur tête avec
l'affaire est ketchup
[Rires]
est un produit normalisé doit contenir à
la base sa matière première donc des
tomates des tomates mûres en très grande
quantité et bien entendu peut se
retrouver sous forme de pâte de purée en
dessous de son va retrouver du vinaigre
du sel et un agent sucrant et des
assaisonnements je n'arrive pas à dire
c'est quoi c'est bon on ne sait pas non
plus non c'est un peu secret chaque
compagnie à ses épices secrètes
[Musique]
celui-là il est plus goût à la tomate et
comme vraiment épais j'ai pas la texture
qu'est-ce que ça doit goûter peut-être
les tomates mais surtout un équilibre
des saveurs de base c'est qu'on parle à
la fois de quatre saveurs principalement
un goût vinaigré un goût sucré un goût
salé la tomate contient aussi ce qu'on
appelle de l'humani naturellement je
rajouterai la touche de couleur des fois
vous parliez qu'on mange avec les yeux
assurément que chop rouge mais ça laisse
son impact sur certains plats
un petit peu épicé mais c'est pas trop
prononcé trop fort
[Applaudissements]
très sucré très très sucré seulement
sont tous faites avec des tomates d'ici
là je pense que c'est un bon argument de
vente d'avoir des tomates d'un
approvisionnement local on ne la chance
de grandir dans une classe où on peut
cultiver plein de choses et abondamment
la tomate plus sucré que ce soit plus
sucré ou tu préfères
[Musique]
vous vous en pensez quoi déjà
la texture est vraiment différente aussi
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'un
fabricant pourrait vouloir avoir une
texture différente ça peut être un choix
d'avoir un ketchup qui est moins lisse
que des particules qui est plus près de
quelque chose qui aurait été fait maison
avec le jaune parce que le petit punch
des pêches tout ce bon ou c'est dur de
dire lequel
des résultats très intéressants
aujourd'hui il y en a vraiment pour tous
les goûts la moitié de nos goutteurs ont
choisi les ketchups classiques je dirais
avec texture lisse igo équilibré mais il
y a de la place pour l'innovation celui
qui s'est démarqué avec 19 voix quand
même c'est un nouveau joueur Canada
sauce un produit local merci à nos
gouttes
[Musique]